digamos que tenemos aquí a la compañía a
que pide un préstamo de un millón de
dólares y este préstamo tiene una tasa
de interés variable le paga al haber más
2% es london interbank offered esto es
labor ahora este es uno de los más
importantes puntos de referencia para
tasas de interés variable y bueno le
paga eso eso se lo va a pagar a un
prestador ésta es la persona que le
prestó el dinero a la compañía a
entonces la compañía tendrá que pagar
una tasa de interés variable por periodo
digamos que en el período 1 por ejemplo
la ifor está en un digamos 5% si la está
en un 5% entonces la compañía a le
tendrá que pagar al prestador un 7% que
son 70 mil dólares ahora digamos ahora
en el período 2 digamos que el eyeborg
baja un poco digamos que el árbol está
en un 4% entonces la compañía tendrá que
pagar 42 son 6 por ciento que es lo
mismo que 60 mil dólares en ese periodo
60 mil dólares de intereses y bueno
ahora supongamos que también tenemos a
la compañía ven la compañía ve también
de un millón de dólares prestados pero
ellos que una tasa fija de interés del
8% 8% tasa de interés fija ahora la
compañía ve independientemente de
cualquier otro punto de referencia de
tasas de interés variable aquí quien le
prestó su prestador es diferente al que
la persona compañía a este puede ser un
banco una compañía incluso un
inversionista así que vamos a ponerle el
nombre para diferenciarlos prestador un
y prestador 2 ahora sin importar el
periodo la compañía ve va a pagar el 8%
de tasa de interés fija entonces por
cada periodo él va a pagar lo que son 80
mil dólares ahora supongamos que ninguna
de estas dos compañías les gusta
realmente su situación digamos que la
compañía por ejemplo no le gusta lo poco
predecible que pueden ser sus pagos
porque dependen del eyeborg y en cambio
la compañía ve cree que está pagando
intereses demás ellos dicen guau mira
las compañías que pagan interés variable
están pagando mucho menos por cada
periodo y quizás también la compañía ve
cree que existe la posibilidad de que el
interés variable baje entonces la iber
puede bajar
y ellos tienen un mayor motivo para
preferir interés variable en préstamo
ahora ellos no pueden salirse de los
acuerdos en los que están no pueden pero
lo que pueden hacer es intercambiar
todos sus pagos en las tasas de interés
así que por ejemplo ellos pueden llegar
a un acuerdo al que se le llama permuta
de tasas de interés el cual consiste
aquí por ejemplo supongamos que la
compañía llega a un acuerdo con la
compañía ve de pagarle digamos el 7% a
la compañía ve de ese millón de dólares
pero de una forma especulativa es un
préstamo especulativo jamás existe ese
préstamo o ese intercambio del millón de
dólares así que la compañía ha llegado a
acuerdo de pagarle el 7 por ciento de
ese millón de dólares imaginario y que
son 70 mil dólares y en cambio la
compañía ve en retorno lo que le dará a
la compañía a es un fuerte abrazo no no
se crean es una tasa de una tasa
variable digamos que él hay formas 1%
entonces este acuerdo consiste en la
formación por ciento y recordemos que es
un especulativo millón entonces
realmente jamás jamás sabrá al
intercambio lo que van a bueno jamás
haré el intercambio del millón sin
embargo si se hará el intercambio de las
tasas de interés con respecto al millón
ahora estoy aquí estoy aquí se le llama
permuta de tasas de interés esta permuta
de tasas de interés ahora lo voy a dejar
aquí para que veas en el siguiente vídeo
que realmente está pagando una tasa de
interés fija esto le está pasando a la
compañía a mientras ella combina sus
pagos entre la permuta y el prestador y
en cambio la compañía ve después de
entrar este acuerdo ellos ahora están
pagando un interés variable